[Musique]
ça vous évoque quoi Camille Claudel vous
la connaissez
un film notamment une forte personnalité
qui était assez devant dans son domaine
et aussi bac a eu une relation assez
connue avec Rodin c'est important pour
vous que des noms de place de rue
portent des noms de femmes pas plus que
ça non c'est pour l'orientation qu'on
donne des noms donc en soi qui est plus
de noms d'âmes ou plus de noms de femmes
ça change rien bonjour madame c'est
votre toute première fois où château de
l'illette première fois oui oui vous
êtes venus à la rencontre de Camille
Claudel ici à la rencontre de Camille de
Rodin oui oui
[Musique]
bonjour à toutes et tous et bienvenue à
Azay-le-Rideau nous nous trouvons place
Camille Claudel qui fait face au
somptueux château de Lille est
elle vit là une partie de son histoire
d'amour passionné avec l'illustre
Auguste Rodin il partage alors leur
passion pour la sculpture Rodin crée son
fameux Balzac Camille sculpte la petite
châtelaine reconnue comme l'une de ses
plus belles créations
à 12 ans soutenu par son père elle prend
des cours avec le sculpteur Alfred
Boucher Rodin prendra le relais elle
collabore alors à l'atelier devient son
modèle s'amuse et sa maîtresse
ils ont 25 ans d'écart et leur histoire
du rat 15 années
gagnant sa liberté Camille Claudel ouvre
alors son atelier et fait des
expositions être une femme sculptrice à
cette époque n'est pas chose facile ses
créations chocs et font fuir les mécènes
à la mort de son père en 1913 elle sera
internée de force pendant 30 ans et
mourra à l'asile en 1943 dans l'oubli
total à l'âge de 70 ans
[Musique]
bonjour Bénédicte bonjour et merci de
vous accueillir dans ce petit bijou
votre château de l'illette ou plane
l'âme de Camille Claudel à Camille
Claudel
sacré personnage qui est toujours là
avec nous finalement Rodin lui avait dit
mais tu as des doigts d'or comment
passer à côté parce que c'est vrai
qu'elle était un peu partagée entre
cette idée de fonder une famille et
cette idée de sculpter et quand elle est
arrivée enceinte à l'yette et que Roda
l'a poussé à avorter ça a été un
dualisme très profond et nous nous
demandons pourquoi elle a fait quatre
petites châtelaines différentes est-ce
l'enfant qu'elle n'a pas eu et qu'elle
attendait qu'elle voulait qu'elle
désirait au plus profond d'elle et c'est
pour ça qu'elle a mis certainement
raison de soi autour d'amour à la
façonner c'est vrai que la personnalité
Camille me touche énormément et elle
touche un peu toute femme je pense que
la promenade dans les jardins peut vous
toucher également puisque ils sont très
avenants
à l'époque vous savez c'était que des
chats du temps de Camille claudelaire
c'est la rivière qui est occupait
essentiellement la vie du lieu merci
beaucoup Bénédicte vous l'aurez compris
ici c'est un véritable voyage des
émotions au château de l'illette un lieu
qui inspire l'amour le bonheur et
d'ailleurs n'oubliez pas des fleurs des
cœurs des couleurs du bonheur même pas
peur
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]